Cindy is a clothing brand that as you
know we're boycotting Israeli products
go to cindy.com. Why? I've been wearing
the products for years for 6, 7, 8 years
from training, gym, boxing, jogging,
praying, covers your aura is this extra
long for the brothers and sisters and
even women's wear. I urge you guys to
check them out inshallah they've got
beautiful beautiful clothing. They have
amazing clothes from them inshallah
brothers and sisters you can see for
yourself with variety of amazing amazing
clothing brothers and sisters that are
suitable for all ages and both genders
inshallah. Enjoy the video. Have you or
someone you know resorted to magic to
solve an issue because they were very
desperate?
Mhm. They've gone to like
>> That's interesting. Is it?
I feel You know I used to like I used to
look into like a big reason I actually
truly
believed in Islam was because I spent
time with some uh
like Jewish wizards. Say wallah. Wasn't
Was it the one who works for Andrew
Tate? No.
No, the numbers one.
So I I I I you know looked into like
numerology and that kind of stuff.
>> I think so, yeah.
Interesting. So what what what what what
what what what what was what what how?
Muslim or as a non-Muslim? No, as a non
as a non as a non-Muslim.
>> So what what made you want to do do
that?
Like was it
>> Seeking truth. I was just seeking truth.
>> seeking truth? Yeah, and I didn't know
that that stuff was you know bad back
then. So how did you find them like On
social media.
It was just on social media. I found a
podcast, you know I had a following so I
connected with him. Yeah, it's Gary the
numbers guy. Who's that? He's a
numerologist online. Okay. So he talks
about like you know and he's Jewish.
Jewish, yeah. What day you were born and
then he like adds up the digits and that
makes your it's this whole thing. Okay,
so what did he say to you? What so as it
what what tell me what what
>> it wasn't I honestly like being around
him, it wasn't necessarily the numbers
that I followed. Like I didn't really
care about that as much, but it was a
lot of the other wisdom that he had
about how this dunya works. So he
acknowledged like jinns are real. Wow.
>> Spirits are real. We'd sit down at a
table and he's not religious, he's not a
religious Jew. And
he would like yell at the waiter be like
and make sure no pork touches this table
even if he didn't even like order pork.
>> Wow.
>> He'd freak out about that.
>> the spiritual ramifications of that.
>> he knew the spiritual ramifications of,
you know, drinking alcohol and like your
spiritual bubble and it opens holes in
that for jin to mess with you.
>> That's crazy. And, you know, watching
porn and stuff like that. It opens up
your spiritual bubble for, you know, jin
to mess with you.
And then he goes Zionist robbers who own
porn hubs. Yeah. He's not even a
Zionist. He's not even a Zionist. Uh but
um So then Yeah, hearing all of that
stuff like a lot of
>> So then is cuz I know another brother
called John Fontaine. He was involved in
psychedelics or
magic. And he's like when he realized
he's like when he heard Islam we believe
in jinn. He was like, "Yo, this This
religion must be the truth cuz he
experienced that reality."
>> So yeah, so with him I kept learning
about you know,
the spiritual shield. But it was only to
a certain extent. Like he would say like
don't eat pork, don't drink, this and
that. He even advised like don't really
sleep around with a bunch of different
women. Like it can, you know, all the
What would it be the esoteric spiritual
things that can happen? You talk about
like if your sink breaks that means like
wealth is going to leave or something
like that.
>> we have stuff like that like if the
glass breaks it's like all problems are
gone now. And then once I kept looking
into Islam and I saw the wisdom in
praying five times a day and maintaining
wudu and ghusl. I was like, "Oh wait,
this is like how to actually protect
your spiritual shield." And so a lot
with the interesting thing with a lot of
these
magic people that I've noticed is they
actually acknowledge the creator. Yeah.
They don't even hide it. They like Gary
for example, he calls him the prime
creator. So he believes in
>> I'm like, okay so did the prime creator
communicate with humanity?"
Through a messenger. He says, "No, it's
like, you know, communicates through
numbers."
And you're supposed to follow the
numbers. You know what I mean? Like
that's where they differ. But then it
also comes out of arrogance like his,
you know, a lot of these guys their
thing is
they don't think that God would have
commanded us to pray.
Because they see it as like God as as
like a higher
They explain it like a demon infiltrated
the message to get our worship and to
take our energy.
When we're only seeking refuge in what
they call the prime creator. Mhm. Cuz
they acknowledge that everything had to
come from one source and that one source
is greater than everything else. Also,
you know,
like there is truth in what they say.
Like they're obviously there's there's
truth in magic and some of that stuff,
but it's not objective and it's not the
100% truth. Like, you know, I was
talking to one of these guys and I was
like, "Yo, like
he was saying like the Celtics are going
to lose cuz it's their enemy year. 100%
they're going to lose." Like all the
numbers leading up to it and then they
won.
And I was like, "Well, like how am I
supposed to submit my life to this? If
the prophet peace be upon him had one
false prophecy, the whole religion would
be a bust." And he didn't have one.
>> Yeah. It's the opposite. Like, the to
make it analogy with sports betting, are
you familiar with how parlays work?
>> No.
Okay, so a parlay is let's say the
Bruins are playing and then there's a
football game, there's a soccer game.
And so you can make one bet
of like the Bruins will win and then the
Patriots will win and then the Celtics
will win. So your odds go from like
the odds become, you know, from like
let's say the it was
you bet, you know, $100 to win 100 for
the Celtics. If you bet on all three
to have a certain outcome, it'll go from
like a from 100 to $100 win to like $100
to win
$5,000. Mhm. Because you you you have to
hit all three bets.
>> Yes. Do you have to Thanks so the odds
become much harder.
>> Yes. So it's like if you had a did a
parlay
of the prophet peace be upon him and all
his predictions, it would be one in the
trillions.
>> No, no, probably
quadrillions, honestly. Yeah. That his
revelation isn't from God.
>> Wow.
It's deep. It's deep. Cuz there's so
many predictions.
>> Yeah, yeah. Uh you know, the Romans
coming back and beating the Persians in
three to nine years, talking about the
prophecies that are happening today, the
scientifical the scientific miracles in
the Quran, the numerical miracles in the
Quran, the linguistic and structural
aspect of it.
>> Historical, yeah. The way I look at it,
it's like you can't prove that it's
anyone from but your creator. And then
it even talks about how, you know,
people not accepting it isn't just
purely intellectual, it stems from the
heart. Yeah. Because intellectually you
can prove Islam is the truth. A lot of
people think like, if a religion is so
obviously the truth, then why doesn't
everyone know it? Or why isn't it
obvious? And I'm like, it is obvious.
>> It is. It is obvious. But you have to
look and you have to pay attention to
the different criticisms that different
faiths get. For example, with
Christians, when we want to
or let's do Judaism. With Judaism, if we
want to criticize their faith, we say,
"Okay, well, we don't believe that, you
know, you say God got tired. You say
that God wrestled a man.
Here's proof that your scripture is
tampered." When they want to criticize
Islam, they don't have theological
arguments for it.
>> don't. They can't disprove that the
Quran is the direct words of God. They
can't disprove that the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, is a false
prophet. They say, "He did this." Yeah,
it's more it's more moral. No, it's it's
logical fallacies.
>> Yes. They resort to a lot of logical
fallacies and taking things out of
context, which is a logical fallacy.
It's under that umbrella.
But that's so fascinating. Or they say,
"Why are Muslim countries dumps?"
Logical fallacy.
>> Yeah, exactly. You can't that that
doesn't make any sense. You know, you
could that then I would say, "Well, why
is, you know, Christian country in
Africa a dump?" Like that's not a point
you can make.
Can I be honest, bro? The week after my
shahada, I drank.
What's something you've done that you
never thought you could?
Do not say, "If only I had done
something else." Verily, the phrase "if
only" opens the way for the work of
Satan. My family was begging me to go to
church with them, you know, like, "Come
on, it's Christmas. You got to go to
church. Like, what are you doing? You
you're not going to come to church now?"
First 40 minutes was like, "Am I at a
Beyoncé concert, or am I here to praise
God?"
>> What's the biggest misunderstanding
you've caused?
There's not a single successful
relationship in my entire family.
When did you feel undeserving of love?
What is one question that Allah will ask
you that you would be terrified to
answer?
If I'm getting arrogant at all, like
just make my
the big reason I actually believed in
Islam because I spent time with some of
Jewish wizards. Say wallahi. Wallahi.
The way I told my family I accepted
Islam wasn't the right way.
Let's play a game.